okay so you should have your books out
by now unless you are um balloon
deficient it's okay I'm balloon
deficient but I prepared earlier and
they're heading his rates of change now
while you're finishing up the blowing of
those balloons I just want to show you I
did a bit of measurement to see what was
going on that is not the intended
purpose of those balloons veteran-owned
okay now if you'll have a look at with
me every would have something slightly
different but here's what idea can you
see my horizontal axis can you actually
see I've labeled it you see what my
horizontal axis is what is it have a
look it's breaths right so I've got oh
I've got a one breath balloon yes I have
pathetic asthmatic lungs I have a to
breath balloon three breaths and so on
and then what I'm measuring here is the
radius of the balloon now in fact what
I've done is I haven't measured the
radius i've actually measured if you
look here good try Michael
I've actually measured the diameter and
then key see what I've done have a look
I've measured the diameter and I've have
did okay so when I'm plotting here I'll
just activate the plot for you bigger
there's my graph of breaths against
radius
now here's what I love about this right
what would you expect to be the
relationship between breaths and radius
and please forgive me I know there's
issues of like air pressure and all in
surface tension and the elasticity in
here let's not worry too much about it
when you when you inject breaths into
the balloon what are you increasing your
we actually you're increasing a lot of
things but in terms of what you're
increasing at a linear rate you're
increasing I would say the volume right
like you're you're putting a number of
molecules of breath of air into the
balloon right and you can see okay Erin
you're gonna have to count down I think
you're hyperventilating my friend
you can see that as volume increases
radius also increases but not at the
same rate do you know that
notice that what do you expect to be the
relationship between radius and volume
think about this this is roughly anyway
it's roughly spherical yeah so what's
the relationship if you if you have a
look at the at the screen if you squint
at my equations there's a bit of a
spoiler there to get from radius to
volume you cube right there's a there's
a constant out the front 4/3 pi right
but essentially it's a cutie
well done good try there's a cube
relationship here right can you just
don't just leave it in just leave it
thank you because now we have to wait
for you thank you so if there's a cubic
relationship between radius and volume I
can look at that B that we spent like a
good two weeks on this topic I can look
at that as an inverse relationship right
can you see the shape here this is not a
cubic curve this is a cube root curve
isn't it can you see how it tapers off
now if you actually graph on to here
this is the cube root of x at least on
my scale okay you'll notice it doesn't
quite line up that's because of the size
of the balloon and the size of your
breaths everyone will have something
slightly different but if I have a look
at mine you'll say how am I gonna get it
to line up
no I Qantas there we go it's gonna be a
bat there there we go you can see as you
increase breaths as you increase volume
I know it's slightly off but that's
because I'm using the very scientific
unit of mr. Wu's breaths and you are to
hear your own ones so obviously we're
not going to get complete consistency
but to be honest I'm actually I'm
quietly impressed with that do you
actually see that relationship that you
expect does that make sense okay now if
you want you can draw yourself a rough
version of this to illustrate what's
going on underneath the heading of rates
of change let's switch gears now switch
this off
what I want to get across two years
we've been using calculus as a lens to
understand two basic things right
we've been understanding gradient and
we've been using the derivative for that
right like this and we've also been
thinking about what's the opposite of
gradient when we think about this in
calculus terms it's so when we don't
differentiate but integrate like this
right you don't get gradient you get
think about it geometrically you get
area right think although back to when
we first introduced the topic of
integration we said this is the problem
we are trying to solve
okay now gradient an area or you could
also add volume onto that if you wanted
to because it's a fairly easy extension
of that like so these are all we've been
limited limited to because the only
derivatives integrals we've been really
working with in a substantial formal way
and when you've got X's and Y's in other
words we're on the Cartesian plane okay
but the wonderful thing about
derivatives and integrals is that we can
use them to compare like this for a
second just look up we can use
derivatives and integrals to compare the
change that's all the D stands for right
D for Delta Delta is in change the
change between any two things any two
quantities now when you compare Y and X
you get rise over run that's why you get
gradient right but you can compare any
things you like for instance in this
situation here there's a variety of
different things that we could muck
about with a variety of different
quantities that change in relation to
each other
does that make sense